[Applause]
[Music]
India is the world's largest movie
producer we've all heard of Bollywood
but let me ask you a question
what's the second largest movie producer
what comes after India
[Music]
the answer is Nigeria yep I'm sure
almost nobody guessed that right but my
dear viewers so-called Nollywood
produces more titles a year than
Hollywood itself but of course nobody
knows this because Africa is the
Forgotten continent African politics and
economics hardly appear in the
newspapers and this is why we can say
that Africans are witnessing a silent
miracle until the 2000s this region it
seemed completely dude but since the
beginning of the new century Africans
have tripled their income countries like
Ethiopia are growing at a rate of 10%
year after year
[Music]
and I know what you're going to tell me
you're gonna say what come on Simon
these are just statistics is life really
changing for the average African look if
you're expecting to see skyscrapers and
caravans of BMWs on the streets of
Nairobi then yes you are going to be
disappointed we're not there yet in fact
there are still regions of the continent
stark and extreme poverty that would be
the case with the People's Republic of
Congo and the Central African Republic
this other regions are improving for
example at us over the ethiopian capital
is starting to get some supermarkets
this might seem like a rather trivial
thing to you but it's a giant step if
you remember that 30 years ago the whole
country was going through one of the
worst famines in history hold on a
minute because there's even more we are
starting to see how African companies
are expanding internationally for
example Ethiopian Airlines or m-pesa a
mobile phone payment platform
so now you might be wondering why is
Africa growing like this what has
changed in the continent and the answer
is clear and that's peace you see the
first requirement for a country to
develop is not do have to fight in wars
after that we can discuss political
systems tax policies or whatever but a
society that lives on a battlefield can
hardly prosper but now things are
starting to change
is that true sounder absolutely Simon
for decades Africa was a really violent
continent wars for independence tribal
clashes genocide today while violent
conflicts do still exist around the
continent from Libya to the say hell to
the Democratic Republic of Congo the
conflicts are less frequent or at least
smaller in scale for example in the year
1990 an average of forty five 400,000
Africans died in violent conflicts today
this figure has dropped to about eight
per 100,000 and of course this has
helped encourage trade and foreign
investment especially from China
nevertheless as we said before there is
still a lot of work to be done Africa is
far from being a prosperous region they
need to take the next step ins or what's
that well that would be
industrialization so far Africa remains
a rural consonant except for a few
exceptions everything you can buy in
Africa is a raw material and it's hard
to grow a modern economy based on
agriculture and mining so this is the
context in which this news takes place
[Music]
the largest free trade deal in nearly a
quarter century seeks to make Africa a
single market yep you had that right the
goal of this treaty is to make an
African version of the European single
market which was the seed for what we
know of today as the European Union
since May the 30th 2019 this treaty has
been a reality we're talking about 52
countries who have signed us in fact
only Benin Nigeria and Eritrea have
refused to enter these so-called f-c FTA
or just C FTA so now the question is can
this treaty change things or is it just
a bunch of nice words can a free-trade
agreement really improve lives in Africa
and why doesn't Nigeria the country with
the largest African economy want to sign
it well today we're going to answer all
of these questions but before we do
let's take a look back at the history
market no industry when we talk about
Africa we should remember one thing 55
countries 1.3 billion people we
shouldn't really talk about Africa like
it's a country then again there is one
thing that most of the African countries
have in common their colonial past most
of these nations have been independent
for less than 50 years and believe me
they still maintain their bonds with
their previous colonizers in many ways
the idea of Independence is kind of a
delusion look in a normal country the
main trading partner is that country's
neighbors American trades with Mexico
and Canada France trades with Germany
Germany trades with the Netherlands but
African countries are different animals
in this regard for example Ivory Coast
is neighbouring garner and Liberia but
who is Ivory Coast's main trading
partner no it's not either of their
neighbors their main trading partner is
the Netherlands and France which
surprise surprise is its former
colonizer
[Music]
and of course this trend is changing but
not in the way you might expect if
you've been following visual politic for
a long time you already know that China
has been increasing its sway in Africa
over the past several years and it's not
only the Asians that are playing a role
here just look at this news
China's coming slow down opens doors to
expanding African trade with India but
not only that over the last 15 years
trade with Africa has tripled with other
countries like Turkey and Indonesia
today Asia represents 45 percent of the
African foreign trade Europe is 30
percent so as you can see there's only a
little share for inter-african trade and
I know what you're thinking right now
you're probably thinking so what I mean
don't we live in a globalized economy I
mean what's the problem with trading
with Asia or Europe well it is a problem
think about it what does Europe or Asia
buy from Africa yep you guessed it raw
materials like oil gas gold and uranium
in other words everything you accept
manufactured goods and there is a good
reason for this let's look at an example
[Music]
Rwanda motorcycle company was born in
they manufacture low-cost motorbikes
would you buy one of those probably not
their bikes are no match for Suzuki or
Honda so Asian and European countries
tend to not opt for a Rwandan model when
they could have a Japanese or American
one instead so where could Rowan's and
motorcycles find markets and of course
that's in other African countries in
fact Africa is a great place for them
because there are almost no competitors
if you live in Congo good luck finding a
BMW sharp to buy a bike from so in many
countries these Rwandan entrepreneurs
have a big blue ocean of market
opportunities to exploit this explains
why despite African countries trading so
little with each other most of the
things they trade are manufactured goods
in other words if Africa wants do you
have industry they need to trade with
each other more so what's the problem
here the problem is that things in
Africa are never easy
and trade is harder than anything there
are lots of tariffs and lots of
bureaucracy that makes it almost
impossible for local companies to cross
borders if you want to send your Rwandan
motorcycle to neighbouring Congo you'll
have to pay tariffs up to 20% but you'll
also have to bribe the guard at customs
otherwise your merch could be waiting
there for months
[Music]
at this the insecurity the gangs and the
warlords that are still present in many
regions and you've got a bit of a
problem don't forget that just a few
years ago many of these countries were
killing each other citizens
so again bike manufacturer in Rwanda can
hardly survive with a small and poorer
market as the local one if they want to
survive they need to expand to their
neighbours in other words protectionism
is making it almost impossible of Africa
to develop the pay attention now because
this might actually change
[Music]
African Union Blood Diamond is a
Hollywood movie that talks about how we
can end up killing each other just for
some precious minerals the conclusion of
this movie is that the West just wants
Africa's resources and nothing more
presented with this situation many might
think that Africans can't get themselves
together and they need a good old
Western helping hands but of course this
is visual politic and you know we think
differently British story has been
written by others we need to own our
problems and solutions and write our
story Paul Kagame Paul Kagame is the
Rwandan presidents in a previous video
we told you about his light side and dis
dark side his motto country is Singapore
so you can imagine that he's not a big
fan of democracy or human rights but
from an economic point of view he has
become an African champion for
Prosperity the thing is
apart from governing Rwanda Kagame is
also the president of the African Union
this organization was created in 2001
inspired by the European Union their big
dream is to turn Africa into a single
market just like Europe and so far it
does seem like they're achieving their
goal
[Music]
Africa's free-trade area comes in two
forthwith Gambia's ratification yes
Divya this is the C FTA that I mentioned
earlier in this video the African
continental free trade agreements their
ultimate goal is to have a common
currency for the whole continent
something similar to the euro but in
Africa we might have to wait 15 or 20
years to witness this but they are
trying very hard
[Music]
but hold on a minute because not
everything is sunshine and rainbows
Spence we always say the devil is indeed
in the details you see in this world we
have free trade agreements and then we
have free trade agreements an example of
the latter would be Marcus or Marcus or
was born in order to create free trade
in South Africa has it worked well the
answer is no the countries who signed
this document were not willing to cede
sovereignty nobody was willing to
promote Arif sand let's their local
companies compete with foreign ones the
Mercosur treaty is full of exceptions
yes it has nice words in it but when you
look at the reality they realized that
the trade between its members hasn't
really increased something similar could
happen with the African free trade area
for example the main African economies
South Africa and Nigeria are not big
fans of this South Africa signed at the
last minute but Nigeria well this is
what my dear sir
see FTA I won't allow Nigeria to be a
dumping ground Muhammadu Buhari
president nigeria basically many
governments are reluctant to lose
control of the small industries they
already have besides their main income
is what they collect in tariffs don't
forget that in a country like Nigeria
there is no big and regulated job market
so it's hard to collect income tax in
most cases African governments get their
money from the only thing they can
control and that's foreign trade but
there is more to this the CFT a treaty
generates as many doubts as it does
hopes you see a treaty like this usually
takes decades to negotiate this one it
was done in only four years and in their
desire to have as many countries as
possible they've left lots of things off
of the negotiation table
final documents is vague and generic it
doesn't say anything clear about
competition causes investments or
intellectual property rights there is no
list of what goods you can trade freely
ins which ones will be protected in Siri
they have committed to removing tariffs
on 90% of the products over the next
decade of course governments can push
the most important goods inside of that
10% so if you only liberalize trade on
the goods that you don't actually sell
then you don't really have free trade
but hold on a second because there are
many many more problems of course the C
FTA would be wonderful as a way to
incentivize the emergence of new
industries but so far Africa relies
heavily on agriculture and to what to
African farmers think well many of them
are not exactly happy smugglers thrive
as Nigeria tries to keep foreign rice
away in this case Nigeria is afraid of
neighboring the neem the neem has become
a big importer of Thai rice apparently
Thai rises high quality and affordable
if Nigeria suddenly opens trade with
Benin its local rice producers might
have a hard time this is where the big
time dilemma comes in should we risk the
agriculture that we have already in
exchange for would be brand new
industries or do we just leave
everything as it is
and this is the real debate according to
the United Nations if the CFDA turns out
the way it was meant to inter-african
trade could grow 52 percent in the year
2022 this is only three years after the
year that we made this video but of
course if the member countries keep
adding exceptions and mistrusting each
other
we could end up with a Merck assort kind
of thing in other words our friends from
the Rwandan motorcycle company would
keep struggling to open markets
elsewhere and remember with no market
there is no industry at all so the
question now goes to you do you think
the C FTA will go in a European Union
like direction or will it go with a more
murca source style also should Nigeria
sign it well we witnessed the
industrialization of the African
continent well please leave your answers
in the comments section below also
please do visit our friends from the
reconsider media podcast they provide
the vocals in this episode that were not
mine and of course do not forget that we
publish brand new videos like this every
week so subscribe to this channel and
hit that Bell button so you don't miss
any posts and if you like this video
give us a thumbs up and as always I'll
see you next time if you want to learn
more about politics and world affairs
and here's some more of my lovely voice
come check out the reconsidered podcast
where we don't do the thinking for you
find reconsider @ww re consider mediacom
or on Apple or Google Play or your
favorite podcast